[Musica]
Io vi parlo di innovazione parlo delle
sfide degli effetti della potenzialità
dell'Innovazione in un quadro di
sostenibilità viste dal punto di vista
del termimentazioni finanziarie cioè da
chi li deve finanziare ma col supporto
di una storia imprenditoriale
e per intendersi L'innovazione di cui
parlo è quella di tutti i giorni quella
che vediamo tutti siamo consapevoli che
la nostra vita quotidiana è
completamente diversa da quella del
generazioni che ci hanno preceduto
oramai in realtà dalla nostra stessa e
dieci anni fa o dei quando eravamo
piccoli ma per un enorme susseguirsi di
cambiamenti e abbiamo la prima
consapevolezza che questo ha riguardato
tutte le generazioni e quindi parliamo
di quell'insieme di cose che sappiamo
avere un effetto positivo ma ci lasciano
tutta una serie di dubbi abbiamo il
dubbio che sia positivo o non positivo
perché ci sono degli effetti collaterali
che vediamo continuamente delle cose che
ci lasciano delle perplessità la
sostenibilità
e il futuro sono una delle
preoccupazioni di questi tempi io ho
scelto qui un'immagine del fratello del
mio bisnonno Vittorio Sella stiamo
parlando del
1891 quindi 130 anni fa e questo è una
delle milioni di immagini che avrei
potuto scegliere per raccontare gli
effetti gli altri effetti
dell'Innovazione che vediamo e con cui
ci interroghiamo Allora Ovviamente io
non ho la pretese da risposta dal punto
di vista esistenziale non sono titolato
però so che ciascuno di noi Specie se
imprenditore ha bisogno di chiavi di
lettura bisogna di qualche cosa Che lo
guidi nel dare un significato a quello
che fa quando parla di innovazione e la
mia risposta nasce in realtà dalla
storia a cui alla fortuna di appartenere
la famiglia Sella inizia la sua attività
imprenditoriale nel 1570 quindi stiamo
parlando di
un mondo lontano nel tempo 450 anni è
molto monarchico nobiliare in cui
l'aspettativa di vita erano meno di 35
anni l'anno alfabetismo dal Cento si
viveva del proprio corpo o di un terreno
per sopravvivere certamente non c'erano
le macchine non c'era cartamoneta Non
c'era trasporti rapidi spesso non ci si
allontanava dal posto in cui si era nati
quindi la consapevolezza in questa
storia che la prospettiva la prosperità
di una famiglia nascono e qui lo
ritroviamo in famiglia come nella
esperienza quotidiana sempre dal
continuo innovare ma L'innovazione di
per sé non è la stessa cosa Qui ho
scelto una immagine di quello che è
accaduto dopo i primi 250 anni cioè
l'avvento in una famiglia Tessile della
fabbrica dal mondo agricolo al mondo
questa scatola all'interno del quale
bisogna far funzionare tutto Allora la
fabbrica in realtà racconta l'immenso
sforzo che quella generazione fece per
riconcere tutto ricominciare gli schemi
riconceri l'educazione e riconciliare il
modello di business concepire
i patti e le regole coi giovani Allora
il primo messaggio che mi dà la storia è
che nessuna innovazione è positiva se
non la accompagni con il cambiamento dei
comportamenti con l'apprendimento della
conoscenza con il nuovo modo per
rispettare i tuoi valori nel contesto
nuovo in cui sei arrivato cioè
l'innovazione funziona solo ed
esclusivamente se accompagnata da un
cambio della curva avanzamento della
conoscenza
ma il secondo elemento forse più
importante
sta nelle motivazioni che cosa ha
guidato perché la famiglia è innovata ma
qui il più dubitosi giustamente diranno
Come diavolo fai a rispondere a
oggettivamente su 450 anni di
innovazione su cosa diavolo ha guidato
l'innovazione In effetti non non Presumo
l'oggettività Ma la nostra famiglia ha
creato una fondazione per conservare la
memoria per conservare gli iscritti per
conservare oggetti e manufatti e quello
che trovi leggendo che poi ti viene
trasmesso anche nella nella storia
familiare nei valori che ti sono
insegnati e che innovi per fare qualcosa
di buono per avere degli effetti
positivi in una famiglia manifatturiera
soprattutto in genere per fare
l'interesse del tuo cliente che è la
base ma spesso per migliorare le
condizioni di chi ci lavora talvolta per
portare avanti i valori in cui credi
per migliorare qualcosa per avanzare la
conoscenza questo è sempre stato
l'obiettivo di chi è innovato il
profitto che è spesso posto in tread off
è stato quasi più una condizione è un
mezzo per poter innovare e una
conseguenza perché capite che è
un'impresa Se l'innovazione non la
trasforma è qualcosa di profittevole non
ha un futuro Quindi deve farci bene
attenzione ma in questo non deve
distogliere il motivo dell'Innovazione
quello che noi chiameremo oggi e purples
e di fatto nel lungo periodo il parpos e
il profitto non sono mai in competizione
e in contraddizione tra di loro Questi
due grandi insegnamenti di una storia di
450 anni sono un po' la chiave con cui
mi accingo finalmente entrare nel
presente e nel futuro Allora
l'innovazione oggi
e la sfida oggi è di nuovo lo faccio dal
punto di vista dell'intermediazione
finanziaria e non dal punto di vista
della genomica dell'esplorazione dello
spazio che sarebbero molto più
interessanti però la sintesi è che nel
mondo in cui che noi osserviamo abbiamo
due grandi forze Oh c'è due grandi
fenomeni semplificandoli Ovviamente se
ne sarebbero milioni Ma il primo
riguarda il fatto che il combinato
disposto di informatica retti e
intelligenza artificiale sta facendo
portando questa generazione essere
quella che entra in un mondo in cui
qualcosa di nuovo cosiddetta rivoluzione
digitale
automatizzando potere del nostro
pensiero del nostro cervello fa per la
storia dell'uomo l'equivalente di quello
che è stato la scoperta dell'Agricoltura
o la rivoluzione industriale quindi
qualcosa di potenziale enorme che ci fa
anche un po' timore tra le conseguenze
che
la digitalizzazione ha cambiato
l'innovazione stessa che è molto più
rapida se ne osserva
l'esponenzialità non è una legge ma
un'osservazione e tra le altre cose si è
capito che l'innovazione nasce dal
contaminazione delle idee nasce in
contesti aperti in ecosistemi più ampi
quindi abbandonandosi Los abbandonando
la ricerca tradizionale in ecosistemi
aperti Quindi con parole come
competizione collaborazione ecosistema
con un potenziale immenso ma allo stesso
tempo e torno all'immagine di prima noi
vediamo di essere vicini sappiamo che la
specie umana Se continua così non ha
tanto tempo ed è vicina è una condizione
di sopravvivenza poi io scelgo un
impatto ambientale che non è Quello
principale se ciascuno di voi è
appassionato a qualche altra sfida
faccia pure riferimento però abbiamo
questa sorta di 3/8 E allora come si
affronta e di nuovo venendo al nostro
mestiere nel nostro mestiere Cosa posso
condividere con voi per mestiere non è
molto amato quello delle intermediazione
finanziaria non è molto amato ma tutti
siamo abbastanza consapevoli che ha
un'importanza immensa un ruolo sociale
immenso Di fatto si fa confluire il
risparmio verso gli investimenti è un
po' come il sangue nel nostro corpo se
ci esclude come ci muoviamo abbiamo
bisogno che circoli quindi c'è una
contropartita economica di quasi
qualunque cosa noi facciamo quale
qualunque sogno attività o insieme
quindi è abbastanza chiaro che se
l'intermediazione finanziaria funziona
bene tutto funziona bene l'impatto
positivo la sostenibilità non può che
passare attraverso un'intermediazione a
sua volta sostenibile d'impatto positivo
Allora qui la prima informazione da
condividere che L'innovazione di per sé
aiuta moltissimo la locazione efficiente
delle risorse la corretta gestione di un
patrimonio la corretta valutazione di un
credito di detto si basano su
informazioni su processi decisionali
Allora accesso alle informazioni i dati
l'intelligenza artificiale La rendono
più facile così come la rendono più
accessibile la possibilità che la
tecnologia che consente di entrare in
ogni singolo telefono poi ci sono cose
come layot
delle cose l'altra sono le distribuite
leggerete tecnologici quelle che
comunemente conosciamo come blockchain i
registri distribuiti che sono delle
delle reti decentrate che consentono a
fianco di quella centrati e gestire
diversamente questi asset digitali che
programmati in un certo modo permettono
come tecnologia di risolvere qualunque
cosa noi abbiamo la fortuna di essere
una generazione Che dispone di una
tecnologia che permette una forte
inclusività permette di ridurre le
barriere permette di valutare bene il
rischio per mettere accelerare i tempi e
ridurre i costi quindi possiamo
chiaramente contribuire positivamente
alla risoluzione dei temi più ampi della
sostenibilità e qui allora Che cosa
rende l'intermediazione
sostenibile Allora l'interpretazione Ha
un impatto se supporta progetti che
siano a loro volta sostenibili cioè che
danno un contributo verso il
miglioramento sulle dimensioni sociali e
ambientali e qui come si fa Cosa vuol
dire dove si ricerca e mi viene in mente
e viene in aiuto la storia del passato
che di fatto la prosperità è nata
dall'innovazione dal suo utilizzo qui
uso due immagini e due fotografie quindi
recenti un po' forti specie quella di
sinistra quella di sinistra una storia
crudele però è una buona immagine che
racconta Da dove viene l'uomo quello che
potete immaginarvi l'uomo
10.000 anni fa 20.000 anni fa in lotta
con la fatica di sopravvivere e oggetto
degli animali a destra invece l'immagine
di oggi dove L'operazione si è invertita
una delle ultime due femmine di
rinoceronte bianco i maschi si sono
estinti il patrimonio genetico si sta
cercando di trovarlo difesa estremamente
da un uomo esausto questo è passato e il
presente quello che a me comunica Questa
immagine è che è difficile che si possa
tornare indietro
è difficile chiedere che la strada è
tornare indietro sia quella giusta E
altrettanto difficile che stare fermi
possa essere una strada quindi il
messaggio che che io voglio dare che
arriva dalla storia è di avere fiducia e
di andare avanti l'innovazione da questa
sfida si esce in avanti si esce usando
l'innovazione
usando l'innovazione per risolvere il
problema Come del resto dimostrano
alcuni casi quello più eclatante questo
quello del buco dell'ozono dove In 40
anni la consapevolezza del problema la
collaborazione internazionale la
modifica del comportamento e tanta
innovazione Abbiamo affrontato e risolto
un problema partendo dalla
consapevolezza e usando è la innovazione
insieme alla collaborazione Allora
questa strada è forse il messaggio
principale che noi abbiamo bisogno di
supportare nessuna innovazione riesce a
essere positiva se non l'accompagniamo
da uno sforzo grande di valutare le
conseguenze di interiorizzare gli
effetti di modificare i comportamenti
e lì viene il dubbio a qualcuno dice sì
ma tutte le risposte non ci sono e qui
c'è l'innovazione gli ecosistemi la
strada della contaminazione si è appreso
e lo stiamo imparando in ogni dove che
gli ecosistemi ci portano a trovare le
soluzioni qui la strada che noi abbiamo
adottato e di prendere il vecchio
Lanificio che è di un modello che pian
piano si sta superando e trasformarlo in
un’opera Innovation Center orientato
all'impatto per creare quella
contaminazione per cercarne soluzioni
fa parte del cambiamento dei
comportamenti e allora questi messaggi
Ci dicono che bisogna che non si può
guardare al passato che non si può
restare fermi bisogna andare avanti e
che si può fare trovando il modo per
farlo e qui viene il concetto
dell'impatto l'impatto è possibile è
possibile se si indirizza all'incrocio
queste forze che l'innovazione per
migliorare il prodotto per fare
l'interesse del cliente per migliorare
il servizio con criterio di
sostenibilità e per un parpus oggi
questo è possibile e il messaggio che vi
dà i è dal punto di vista
intermediazione finanziaria e che non
c'è più quello che viene temuto Trade
off non c'è più ormai con tempi molto
più veloci prima lo vedevi nel lungo
periodo non c'è più il tredoff tra il
profitto lo sostenibilità Anzi da chi se
ne occupa vi posso dire il contrario
oggi è assai improbabile che vi sia una
sostenibilità economica
non dico di lungo periodo ma di medio
periodo di qualcosa che non abbia una
pari sostenibilità sociale o ambientale
quindi è arrivato finalmente il momento
di indirizzare le nostre forze
totalmente su questo nelle mie
conclusioni sono che in questo scenario
tutt'altro che semplice ma bellissimo Io
vedo ancora più opportunità che minaccia
ovviamente non penso che sia possibile
tornare indietro non lo credo Non lo
rendo credibile non penso e si possa
stare fermi bisogna andare avanti usando
l'innovazione usando l'innovazione per
avere un impatto positivo partendo da la
conoscenza la consapevolezza che si deve
fare che non vi ha confetti e usando
soluzioni come come ad esempio gli
ecosistemi con l'obiettivo di migliorare
di avere un impatto positivo Questa è la
visione è il messaggio che io vi lascio
credo che avrà successo chi fa questo e
Ritengo che l'intermediazione
l'innovazione i nostri investimenti e le
nostre scelte debbano essere orientate
all'impatto Grazie